Samsung has just announced its Galaxy S
10 line of smartphones and the sn+ model
is looking really impressive let's talk
about the five features that are a step
ahead of Apple's iPhone 10s for starters
the new Infinity o display is a game
changer it's very color accurate and
incredibly bright display mate measured
a peak brightness of up to 1200 nits
compared to 725 on the iPhone Tenace max
that's actually a pretty massive
difference making the S 10s display the
brightest in the industry this also
helps it achieve HDR 10 plus support
which is more widely supported than the
iPhone 10 SS Dolby vision support since
ACR 10 plus is royalty-free for video
production companies the s tens display
is also the most color accurate display
in any smartphone with slightly better
tcpip three color accuracy than Apple's
iPhone 10s Mac's we haven't yet seen the
display in person but we'll be comparing
it to the tennis Maxx as soon as we get
our hands on it from the looks of it
Apple's gonna have to add pro motion
technology to their 2019 iPhones if they
want to top Samsung's infinity o display
for the second feature it's the design
there were a few things that bugged me
about the older Samsung smartphone
designs that kept the iPhones on a step
above Samsung but all those things seem
to be finally perfected with s 10 first
of all the display is notch --less with
a hole-punch camera cutout that's cut
using a laser so the surrounding pixels
aren't damaged I've gotta admit that the
cutout looks great and it allows for a
truly edge to edge display that's
incredibly immersive the fingerprint
sensor is finally gone from the back of
the phone making it look incredibly
clean in the addition of another lens
makes the camera bump longer and more
aesthetically pleasing even better the
SN Plus gets two new ceramic finishes
that you can get if you pay for at least
512 gigabytes of storage ceramic is
harder tougher and more scratch
resistant than glass although it's
harder it can still crack like glass but
maybe not as easily the ceramic model is
also a bit heavier so it should make for
a more premium feel nonetheless I still
prefer the look of my iPhone 10s max the
design changes to the S 10 just make it
look futuristic and modern compared to
their older galaxy flagships
now let's talk about that fingerprint
sensor it's under the display so it's
completely hidden in the location is
just perfect
so convenient compared to having it on
the back the best part about it is that
it's an ultrasonic sensor instead of an
optical sensor which means that it
actually uses bursts of sound to map the
fingerprint which is similar to the
sonar waves that submarines use to map
objects underwater optical sensors
require the phone to blast light onto
your finger in order to read it the
ultrasonic sensor doesn't so you can
actually unlock the SN before you wake
the display which is honestly my
favorite part about it and it should
also be more accurate reliable and
faster than optical sensors Apple is
banking on face ID which works great but
it does have its limitations like when
it's laying flat on a table the 2019
iPhone lineup is rumored to be getting
faster face ID but we're not likely to
see an in display fingerprint sensor
until at least next year for the fourth
feature we've got the cameras inside of
the hole punch cutouts we have a 10
megapixel shooter in the s 10 capable of
shooting 4k video in a wide-angle 8
megapixel camera for depth sensing the
iPhone 10s and 10's max feature a 7
megapixel shooter limited to 1080p 60
this should ultimately make for better
selfie photos and video than with the
iPhone 10 s an exceptional depth sensing
as well on the rear the SN Plus adds a
16 megapixel ultra wide lens which makes
for some pretty awesome looking photos
with wide lens distortion correction if
you shoot 1080p video with the ultra
wide camera you get some incredible
video stabilization but it probably
crops in a good amount the best part
about the camera is that it shoots in
the same HDR 10 plus format that the
display supports which is pretty unique
since even though the iPhone 10s can
shoot great HDR video it still saves the
file in standard dynamic range we'll
have to see just how good the camera is
when we get our hands on it finally
there's a new wireless power share
feature it basically allows your s 10 to
wirelessly charge another Qi compatible
device including even their oldest
wireless charging smart phones in their
new Galaxy buds in terms of charging
your friends smartphone it doesn't seem
very practical since it renders your
phone unusable while charging and you
probably don't want your own battery to
drain down to 30% just to charge their
phone where it really makes sense is
when you want to charge your own
wearable devices like any of the galaxy
smart watches bands are most likely the
new galaxy
buds carrying case since the batteries
and those devices aren't very large you
don't risk draining your whole battery
now the most practical use case for me
is that you can actually plug the SN
into the wall and wirelessly charge
another device on top of it fast
charging 2.0 won't work through the wall
due to heat concerns but it's still
perfect for fully charging another
device and your S 10 at the same time
with only one charger you can't do this
yet with any iPhone but there are rumors
of Apple adding a similar feature to
their 2019 iPhone lineup well be getting
our hands on the Galaxy S 10 as soon as
it gets released so make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on those
videos